so there are seven main pedals that form
the core of the living building
challenge the first has to do with
Place understanding the climate and
impacts that a building may have on its
site the second has to do with the
responsible use of energy on site as
well as water then there's the use of
materials and here the focus is to
eliminate all of these chemicals and
materials that are known to be
destructive either in terms of toxicity
energy or or depletion of resources
around the world and lastly there's a
whole slew of really interesting
criteria including happiness and wellbe
equity and this wonderful category
called biophilic design and that really
opens up an aspirational aspect of the
living building challenge which is to
connect humans with their broader
ecology